I had one of my friends he's in the SEAL
Teams and he had a guy that was that was
not to standards and he brought him into
his office and says hey bro there's no
fat seals and you're fat editing you're
gonna start taking the PRT until you're
good to go so I I sometimes that direct
approach with PRT physical Readiness
test which again in the SEAL Teams
there's not there's not a bunch of
people tracking you and there was years
that go by where the guy a guy can if
you know oh I had a trip wasn't there
for the PRT because like a command like
the Seal team would do one PRT a year
and you'd see it you know months in
advance I go to the PRT is on October
15th or whatever so if a guy's like cool
I'm taking leave or I'm gonna go on a
trip October 15th he's not there you do
that three years in a row your your
pants size could be a 46. you know what
I'm saying